عربت روسي عن امالها في ان تتحلى تركيا
بضبط النفس وان تمتنعا عن اي استخدام
المفرط للقوه في سوريا بعد ان شنت انقره
سلسله غارات جويه اصادفت مواقع للاكراد في
سوريا والعراق وابو عيده تلويح الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بشني هجوم بريه ضد
المقاتلين الاكراد المبعوث الخاص للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى سوريا الكسندر
لافارديف اكد ان روسيا تبذل منذ اشهر كل
ما بوسعها لمنع اي عمليه بريه واسعه
النطاق ضد سوريا ونشد المسؤول الروسي
انقره مواصله العمل مع جميع اصحاب المصلحه
لايجاد حل سلمي بما في ذلك للقضيه
الموقف الروسي جاء من الاسنان عاصمه
كازاخستان حيث سيعقد اجتماع ثلاثي روسي
تركي ايراني بشان سوريا العسكريه التركي
في سوريا رفضته ايضا واكدت معارضتها لاي
عمل عسكري يزعزع استقرار الوضع في سوريا
او هيك سياده العراق وفقه الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي اعرضت ايضا عن تعازيها
لخساره مدنيين في كل من سوريا وتركيا
وتاثير مثل هذا الهجوم على هدفي محاربه
تنظيم داعش فننسى والمانيا اعربتا ايضا عن
قلقهما اذا الغارات الجويه التي شنتها
تركيا وناشدتا انقره النفس
[موسيقى]